[D. Evans] So the answer is the first 3 are correct.
We want to get started programming, and we'll get started programming very soon.
The most important thing is to learn some computer science concepts,
and we'll do that as we get started programming, as well as along the way.
And the third goal is to write code to extract a link from a web page.
That will be the first thing that we do to start building our search engine
and collecting the corpus that we need for our search engine.
The fourth choice is not true.
We're not going to get to the point where we write code to rank web pages this unit.
That's something that we'll be covering in Unit 6.